-We are here celebrating
Thanksgiving with my family.
And so far our older boy, Ashe,
has been very sweet to Axel.
But you found an old baby book
where you filled in information.
And what did you --
did you remember?
How did I treat Josh
when we were that age?
-You were not quite as loving,
I don't think.
You were beloved.
You were the sweetest boy.
And poor Poshy
had a bad stomach situation,
so he was kind of fussy
and not as --
Yeah, he was a harder baby.
-No, I think everybody could
tell that tonight.
[ Laughter ]
-But anyhow, there was once
I remember writing in
the baby book --
you must have been
about 2 1/2 --
and you said, "Just leave Poshy
in his crib today
because he'll be just fine."
-Is that your memory of it
as well?
-I remember that he'd be playing
on the floor and you would --
You know how like a dog can step
over things and never trips?
You could do the same thing.
You would you step over Josh
as if he wasn't there.
But you never tripped over him,
but you just pretty much
ignored his existence.
-I was elusive.
[ Laughter ]
-Like a ninja.
-Yeah.
-You guys figured something out.
I knew that Josh and I are
about two years apart.
And Ashe and Axel
are about two years apart.
But you guys figured out
something pretty amazing.
-Yeah, it's exactly two year--
yeah, the distance --
-Two years and 11 days.
-For both Josh and I
and my two boys,
which is
a fantastic coincidence.
-I always said two years
was the perfect difference.
-And 11 days.
[ Laughter ]
-You end up on the other side of
that 11 days, yeah.
You do not -- We post a lot of
photos of our kids, obviously,
like a lot of parents do.
It's easier than ever now
with photo sharing.
There's one kind of photo of
children you do not care for.
-I don't like food
on those kids' faces.
I don't like it.
I don't like it if kids are
outside playing in the dirt.
That's great.
But, like, covered --
Also your kids have a lot of,
like, green smoothies.
They're keeping it healthy.
And it just looks gross.
I don't like it.
Like, they're cute kids.
I love them.
And I don't like it when they
got stuff all over their face.
And I know you have,
like, rags around.
I know you have wet ones.
-We have the finest rags.
We have Egyptian cotton.
-Yeah.
No, I love pictures of them,
when they got stuff
on their faces.
-And the other thing I noticed
that's happened recently
is when we were walking down
the street about a month ago
and you had Axel in front of you
in a carrier,
and these people
were coming toward us.
Somebody goes,
"Hey, that's Seth Meyers."
And the other person said,
"And that's the lobby baby."
[ Laughter ]
So they're infamous.
-Yeah. He's a lobby baby now.
-He's a lobby baby.
-It's a good way
of living his life, man, yeah.
I just hope he --
You know, he should try to
always look like he does now,
'cause otherwise people are
gonna forget it was him, yeah.
-True.
-We talked a lot about what you
wanted the kids to call you
when you first
became grandparents.
Your original plan was
you wanted to be called...
-Cisco.
[ Laughter ]
And you wanted to be called...?
-I toyed with a bunch of ones,
like my grandmother was Nani,
the Swedish one.
But I didn't really know.
-You didn't really know.
And what happened was we all,
my brother and I, Josh and I,
still call you Hurry and Yarry,
which were nonsense names
we've called you our whole life.
-Right.
-Which were the nonsense names
you guys called each other
when you met.
-Not when we met, no.
-Not the first day.
-No, he was putting moves on me
then.
-"Hey, Hurry!"
[ Laughter ]
"How you feel, girl?"
Snapped her up like that.
[ Laughter ]
-Your pickup line was
to call her Hurry.
-Yeah. Never worked before.
-Yeah.
So that's what he calls you,
is Hurry and Yarry.
-Yeah, but they -- Paca.
He puts the "paca" in front.
-Yeah, he thought --
For whatever reason
Grandpa was Paca.
So, you're Paca Hurry
and Paca Yarry,
so I feel like when they hear
him talking to you in the park,
they think he's from some weird
Eastern European country.
[ Laughter ]
"Paca Hurry!"
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-"Paca Yarry, can we have
iced cream?"
-Oh, no, you don't know
Paca Alexi.
[ Laughter ]